le ministre des transports à québec
sylvain gaudreault veut dit-il donner un
coup de pouce aux transports collectifs
il compte investir près d'un milliard
d'ici 2020 pour entretenir les
infrastructures vieillissantes alors
comprenait entre autres le métro de
montréal
mais le hic c'est que l'argent et le
prince dans le budget pour les routes
comme nous l'expliquent jacques
bissonnet priorité au transport
collectif
le ministre des transports sylvain
gaudreault annonce une stratégie
nationale de mobilité durable ou plus
concrètement comment financer
adéquatement le transport en commun est
la mesure la plus spectaculaire est
l'augmentation de près deux milliards de
dollars d'ici 2020 du budget du maintien
des infrastructures existantes des
sociétés de transport une somme qui sera
prise à même le budget du transport
routier
les ministres se fait d'ailleurs
rassurant cela n'affectera en rien notre
capacité de maintenir un bon et tom nos
infrastructures routières
à l'heure actuelle et qui nous pose un
très grand nombre de défis comme vous le
savez une mesure nécessaire à la stm aux
prises avec des pannes à répétition dans
le métro sont pas suivre et une cliente
le métro vont rouler parce qu'on leur
ait pas parce qu'on a les hommes pour le
faire
c'est la bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on est fier de pouvoir
ajoute voir imposer le gouvernement veut
aussi accroître de 30 % l'offre de
transport collectif et d'ici 2020 par
l'implantation de voies réservées et
l'augmentation des services
le gouvernement se lance aussi dans une
consultation avec les municipalités sur
les moyens de financer équitablement les
neuf plus grandes sociétés de transports
publics dont la plus importante
lester m le job d'un détail on est
vraiment dans la question du financement
comment vos finances et tout ça pour
l'opposition à québec il s'agit de
mesures électoralistes l'espagne
stratégie de mobilité durable stratégie
électorale le ministre gaudreault se
défend d'annoncer des mesures à saveur
électorale il a dit moi je ne suis pas
dans les hypothèses mais bien dans leur
réelle et il ajouté s'il ya des
élections
eh bien nous serons d'abord majoritaire
et nous pourrons donc mettre en
application rapidement toute cette
nouvelle
stratégie issigeac bissonnet radio
canada montréal